ranks 48th in the nation when it comes
to the number of women getting their
annual mammogram and bringing screening
directly to women can make the
difference of early detection and
possibly even saving a life
in tonight's Buddy check aid report the
Nevada ma'am event celebrates 20 years
of reaching rural and urban women during
its nearly two decades Criss crossing
the state the mammoth Anne has screamed
more than 40,000 women we're trying to
bring the same quality screening to all
women regardless of where they live
regardless of their financial means and
bringing it to them by delivering
services the bright pink bus has logged
two hundred and sixty three thousand
miles since 2008 it's not unusual to
find us a jackpot which is at the Idaho
Nevada border fort McDermott Wendover in
about two weeks we'll be in Sandy Valley
offering 3d imaging to smaller
communities or underserved women is the
mammoth and mission it sees nearly 3,000
women a year still though Nevada lags
very far behind the rest of the country
when it comes to the annual exam why do
you think it is that Nevada ranks 48th
in the country for women getting
screened many women that I have run into
it's that if they don't feel it touch it
it doesn't exist we need to do a much
better job as a society to let people
know that that's the whole reason for
the screening is to find it at its
smallest services are offered regardless
of economic status or ability to pay
some clients may be eligible for a free
screening insurance cover screenings at
no cost because it's a preventive
screenings payer source according to the
National Breast Cancer Foundation one in
eight women will be diagnosed with
breast cancer in their lifetime so
health experts urge women 40 and over to
get their mammogram every year so we
call this segment buddy check 8 so you
can remind your buddy to do her monthly
self-exam now you can make an
appointment with the man man by going to
Nevada health centers org click on mamuh
man then go to the calendar and then you
can schedulers are also there's a phone
number you can call so call your buddy
and make sure she gets hers done too